Nearly three years after the COVID-19 pandemic began, the vast majority of Americans have been infected with COVID, and many are ready to declare the pandemic over. But millions of others are still living with the effects of the virus. Estimates of the prevalence of long COVID vary, but there's no doubt that COVID can, in some cases, trigger physical, mental, and cognitive symptoms that can last for months or even years. So what is long COVID, and who is most at risk for it? What are the mental health and cognitive symptoms? How much do researchers know about what causes some people to develop long COVID and not others? How similar is long COVID to other post-viral illnesses? What treatments are available? And are we
在新冠疫情爆发近三年后，绝大多数美国人都感染过新冠病毒，许多人已准备好宣布疫情结束。但仍有数百万人深受病毒后遗症的困扰。关于“长新冠”（long COVID）患病率的估算各不相同，但毫无疑问，在某些情况下，新冠病毒确实会引发持续数月甚至数年的生理、心理和认知症状。那么，什么是长新冠？谁最容易受到影响？心理健康和认知症状有哪些？研究人员对为什么有些人会患上长新冠而另一些人不会，了解到了什么程度？长新冠与其他病毒后遗症有多相似？有哪些治疗方法？我们是否
getting those treatments to the people who need them? Are kids and teens getting long COVID or does it affect mostly adults? And finally, what are the most pressing questions that researchers need to answer now to get help to patients who need it? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today, both of whom are neuropsychologists who work with patients with long COVID. First is Dr. Tracy Van Orsdahl, a board-certified clinical neuropsychologist and associate professor
正在将这些治疗方法提供给有需要的人？儿童和青少年会患上长新冠吗，还是说它主要影响成年人？最后，研究人员现在需要回答哪些最紧迫的问题，才能为有需要的患者提供帮助？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我们邀请了两位嘉宾，她们都是与长新冠患者共事的神经心理学家。首先是特蕾西·范·奥斯达尔（Tracy Van Orsdahl）博士，她是获得委员会认证的临床神经心理学家，也是约翰霍普金斯大学医学院
of psychiatry and behavioral sciences at the Johns Hopkins University School of Medicine. She's a clinician and researcher whose work with patients provides insight and motivation for her research. She has studied cognitive functioning in patients with cancer and other illnesses, and she now studies and treats patients in the Johns Hopkins post-acute COVID-19 clinic. Next is Dr. Rowena Eng, a pediatric neuropsychologist at the Kennedy-Krieger Institute, where she works with children and teens in the pediatric post-COVID rehabilitation clinic. She was part of an interdisciplinary team that recently developed guidelines to help pediatricians and primary care physicians identify and treat long COVID. She's also an assistant professor of psychiatry and behavioral sciences at the Johns Hopkins University School of Medicine.
精神病学和行为科学系的副教授。她是一位临床医生和研究员，与患者的工作为她的研究提供了洞察力和动力。她曾研究过癌症和其他疾病患者的认知功能，现在她在约翰霍普金斯大学急性后新冠肺炎诊所研究并治疗患者。接下来是罗威娜·恩（Rowena Eng）博士，她是肯尼迪·克里格研究所（Kennedy-Krieger Institute）的儿科神经心理学家，在那里她与儿科新冠后康复诊所的儿童和青少年一起工作。她是一个跨学科团队的成员，该团队最近制定了指导方针，帮助儿科医生和初级保健医生识别和治疗长新冠。她同时也是约翰霍普金斯大学医学院精神病学和行为科学系的助理教授。
Thank you both for joining me today. Thanks for having us. I'm excited to be here. Thank you for having me. I mentioned in the introduction that it's tough to pinpoint exactly how many people are suffering from long COVID. Why is that? Do doctors and researchers have any ballpark sense of how large those numbers might be? That's a great question. I think part of the answer depends on how you ask the question.
感谢两位今天加入我的节目。谢谢邀请我们。很高兴能来到这里。谢谢邀请我。我在介绍中提到，很难准确查明有多少人患有长新冠。这是为什么呢？医生和研究人员对这些数字可能有多大有没有一个大概的了解？这是一个很好的问题。我认为部分答案取决于你如何提出这个问题。
If you're looking at patients who are presenting to long COVID clinics, you're likely to see elevated rates of certain patterns of symptoms. And then when you are surveying the general population, individuals who opt into surveys may be more likely to be those who have symptoms, our larger, more epidemiologic studies, that try to cast a wide net of individuals who may or may not have had COVID are probably providing one of the most accurate estimates of long COVID symptom rate out there. So there's nowhere to report it. It's only if you happen to get somewhere in the whole system. If you're checked into a hospital and you're there for a month, we know you've got long COVID.
如果你观察的是前往长新冠诊所就诊的患者，你很可能会看到某些症状模式的比例较高。而当你调查普通人群时，自愿参与调查的人可能更容易是那些有症状的人。我们更大规模的流行病学研究试图广泛覆盖那些可能感染过或未感染过新冠的人，这些研究可能提供了目前关于长新冠症状率最准确的估计之一。所以没有地方可以报告它。只有当你碰巧进入整个系统中的某个环节时才会被记录。如果你住进医院并待了一个月，我们才知道你患有长新冠。
Right. And there are electronic medical record studies that are looking at diagnoses and medically captured symptoms that make it into the electronic medical record. But those are sometimes pretty gross measures of symptom presence. We don't know in some cases whether they existed before COVID, if they came on right with the COVID illness, whether they're late onset symptoms, for example. Dr. Eng, is the prevalence as high among children and teens as it is among adults? Do we even know?
没错。还有一些电子病历研究正在查看诊断结果和进入电子病历的医疗记录症状。但这些有时是对症状存在情况的相当粗略的衡量。在某些情况下，我们不知道这些症状是在新冠感染前就存在，还是在新冠患病时立即出现，亦或是迟发性症状。恩博士，儿童和青少年的患病率是否像成年人一样高？我们知道吗？
Generally, it seems like from what we see across studies and from recent papers out from JAMA, I think that overall there's generally a less lower valence rate of COVID infections among children or children generally. But even within these, we tend to see a little bit lower rate of or generally in of long COVID in children and adolescents. That doesn't necessarily take away the impact of long COVID. but we tend to see a little bit less of a prevalence or at least less risk for COVID among children than adults. And are the symptoms similar? Do children suffer as much as we're hearing that adults are suffering in some cases? We see a lot of overlapping symptoms, but I think it's a little bit different in terms of how frequently it's reported in terms of like the higher, how much that it's as one of the higher impact of all the symptoms type of symptoms that they're presenting compared to adults.
总的来说，从我们通过各项研究以及《美国医学会杂志》（JAMA）最近发表的论文所看到的情况来看，我认为总体而言，儿童感染新冠的患病率通常较低。但即使在这些研究中，我们往往也会看到儿童和青少年患长新冠的比例通常较低。这并不一定削弱长新冠的影响，但我们倾向于看到儿童患长新冠的患病率或至少风险比成年人要低一些。那么症状相似吗？儿童是否像我们听到的某些成年人那样遭受痛苦？我们看到了很多重叠的症状，但我认为在报告频率方面，以及在所有症状中，与成年人相比，这些症状在儿童中作为高影响症状的程度略有不同。
So, for example, children similarly present with fatigue, some having difficulties with physical or exercise or tolerance for exercise, cognitive complaints or having kind of feelings of talking of changes. A lot of have mood, sleep disturbances, headaches. But among children, they do present compared to adults, seem to present a little bit less in terms of cognitive changes compared to adults. We tend to see more along lines of fatigue, sleep disturbance, at least in some more recent studies. Dr. Van Ostroesto, let me ask you this. Long COVID is a new illness because COVID's only been identified among us for about the last three years or so. Is there any official agreement as to what constitutes long COVID and how you diagnose it and how long do the symptoms need to last in order to qualify? That also is a great question. So the World Health Organization has issued guidelines for their criteria for long COVID.
例如，儿童同样会出现疲劳，有些人难以进行体力活动或对运动的耐受力下降，有认知方面的抱怨，或者有某种“说话改变”的感觉。许多人有情绪、睡眠障碍、头痛。但与成年人相比，儿童在认知变化方面的表现似乎略少一些。在一些较新的研究中，我们往往看到更多的是疲劳和睡眠障碍。范·奥斯达尔博士，让我问你这个问题。长新冠是一种新疾病，因为新冠病毒在我们中间被识别出来大约只有三年左右。对于什么是长新冠、如何诊断它以及症状需要持续多久才能符合诊断标准，是否有官方共识？这也是一个很好的问题。世界卫生组织已经发布了长新冠标准的指导方针。
You don't have to have a positive COVID test. The symptoms might come on with the acute illness or they may come on later. They may fluctuate over time. And they generally across diagnostic or guidelines that have been put forth by various governance groups, we tend to think that symptoms need to be present, 12 weeks or longer under most of those systems. There's a lot of work being done to try to harmonize or operationalize long COVID, but it's still a fairly messy construct when you think of diffuse symptom pictures. Some of the symptoms could be fairly prevalent among healthy adults out in the
你不一定非要新冠检测呈阳性。症状可能在急性病发作时出现，也可能稍后出现。它们可能会随时间波动。在各治理小组提出的诊断或指导方针中，我们通常认为症状需要持续12周或更长时间。目前有很多工作正在进行，试图统一或规范长新冠的定义，但当你考虑到弥漫性的症状表现时，它仍然是一个相当混乱的概念。其中一些症状在健康的成年人中可能相当普遍，
population, things like feeling a bit fatigued, having some low mood or anxiety. We know that there are relatively high base rates of those issues. And then these symptoms can come and go over time. So it makes it really challenging to tease apart what is etiologically or causally related to the COVID illness, what is related to the psychosocial stress of living through the pandemic and having an illness. There's a lot to really tease apart. So who is most at risk for a long COVID? Are we seeing more cases among people who are, say, older or immunocompromised, for example? or like what about men versus women? Are there statistical differences there? So in the adult literature, we do tend to see that our patients who are more acutely ill, meaning they required stays in the
比如感到有点疲劳，情绪低落或焦虑。我们知道这些问题的基准发生率相对较高。而且这些症状会随时间反复出现。因此，要理清什么是与新冠疾病在病因学或因果上相关的，什么是与经历疫情和患病带来的社会心理压力相关的，确实非常具有挑战性。有很多东西需要真正理清。那么谁患长新冠的风险最大？我们是否看到更多病例出现在老年人或免疫功能低下的人群中？或者男性与女性相比如何？这方面有统计学差异吗？在成人文献中，我们确实倾向于看到那些病情更严重、意味着需要入住
intensive care unit. They tend to have more persistent long COVID symptoms. And we know that that's common for almost everyone or many populations who end up in the ICU. There's an entire literature on acute respiratory distress syndrome that tells us that being in in the ICU, the social isolation, the proning, the ventilation, many of those factors can contribute to long-term neuropsychological and neuropsychiatric difficulties. But more broadly, we're also seeing long COVID symptoms in individuals who had mild or acute illnesses and who are younger. And in those cases, you know, the risk factors that keep popping up more consistently in the research tend to be female sex and having a history of pre-existing anxiety or depression.
重症监护室（ICU）的患者，往往会有更持续的长新冠症状。我们知道这对于几乎所有人或许多最终进入ICU的人群来说都是常见的。关于急性呼吸窘迫综合征的文献表明，入住ICU、社会隔离、俯卧位通气、机械通气，许多这些因素都可能导致长期的神经心理和神经精神困难。但更广泛地说，我们也看到那些病情轻微或急性、且年龄较轻的个体出现了长新冠症状。在这些情况下，研究中更一致出现的风险因素往往是女性，以及有焦虑或抑郁病史。
Depending on how the research is conducted, we may also see various racial or ethnic backgrounds look more or less likely to experience long COVID. There are some studies suggesting that those with greater socioeconomic deprivation or those who have more health core morbidities may also be at greater risk for long COVID. And Dr. Eng, you're seeing the same thing among the younger cohort? Yeah, we're pretty much seeing very similar risk factors. But I think, you know, we also notice that it seems like at least one more recent study that came out, those who are adolescents, so about 12 and above, seems to be at a little bit higher risk than younger children with on COVID.
根据研究进行的方式，我们可能还会看到不同的种族或族裔背景表现出患长新冠的可能性高低不一。有一些研究表明，社会经济匮乏程度较高或有更多健康合并症的人，患长新冠的风险也可能更大。恩博士，你在年轻群体中也看到了同样的情况吗？是的，我们几乎看到了非常相似的风险因素。但我认为，我们也注意到，至少最近发表的一项研究显示，青少年（即12岁及以上）患长新冠的风险似乎比年幼儿童要高一些。
That being said, it might be a biased reporting because young children don't have them necessarily verbal skills to report symptoms compared to school age and adolescent children. And so I think it's the kind of a measurement issue there, you see. Are people less likely to experience long COVID if they had a mild or a moderate case to begin with rather than severe? And does being vaccinated have any bearing on whether you get long COVID or not? Well, the vaccination question, there seemed to be several studies suggesting that vaccination may be associated with reduced rates of long COVID. The data aren't entirely consistent. and we're not exactly sure how much lower a person's risk is. But certainly we know that avoiding COVID is going to help you avoid long COVID.
话虽如此，这可能是一种报告偏差，因为年幼儿童不一定具备报告症状的语言能力，而学龄儿童和青少年则具备。所以我认为这是一种测量问题。如果人们最初患的是轻度或中度病例，而不是重症，他们患长新冠的可能性是否会降低？接种疫苗对是否患长新冠有影响吗？关于疫苗接种的问题，似乎有几项研究表明，疫苗接种可能与长新冠发病率降低有关。数据并不完全一致，
So everything that we can do to avoid getting COVID in the first place, which includes vaccination, should be protected for long COVID as well. So what if you've been infected with COVID once? Does that reduce your risk for long COVID if you get infected again? Or does it have no bearing? And what about infection with a new strain? I mean, there's so much stuff going on out there that we don't really have our arms around yet. Yeah, I think there's a lot of limited literature regarding kind of like the re-infections and then the complicated sense of like thinking about other factors like vaccinations in between infections as well.
我们也不确定一个人的风险降低了多少。但我们当然知道，避免感染新冠将有助于你避免长新冠。所以我们为了避免感染新冠所能做的一切，包括接种疫苗，也应该能预防长新冠。那么，如果你已经感染过一次新冠，这会降低你再次感染时患长新冠的风险吗？还是说没有影响？感染新毒株又如何呢？我的意思是，外面发生的事情太多了，我们还没有完全掌握。是的，我认为关于重复感染，以及考虑到两次感染之间接种疫苗等其他因素的复杂性，相关文献非常有限。
You know, I think there's a now multi-site studies like recover from the National Institute of Health trying to look at these more controlled kind of factors, thinking about these different variables. But right now, I think there's still quite limited literature to suggest in terms of thinking about if there's going to be different presentations or how much different presentation or how kind of significant in terms of severity of symptoms or anything like that changes with secondary or tertiary or third time kind of infections. There's a lot more limited kind of comparable evidence, I think, to kind of look into that. You both see patients who come into your clinics with cognitive concerns? What kind of symptoms are they experiencing? So from the adult side, you know, I think many folks have heard of the term brain fog throughout this pandemic. And as a neuropsychologist, I'm not a
你知道，我认为现在有像美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）发起的“RECOVER”这样的多中心研究，试图观察这些更受控的因素，思考这些不同的变量。但目前，我认为关于二次、三次感染是否会导致不同的表现，或者症状的严重程度会有多大变化，相关文献仍然非常有限。我认为，要研究这些问题，可供参考的证据非常有限。你们两位都在诊所接待有认知问题的患者吗？他们正在经历什么样的症状？从成人方面来看，我认为在整个疫情期间，许多人都听说过“脑雾”这个词。作为一名神经心理学家，我不是
huge fan of the term because it lacks the type of specificity that I like to work in. But our patients are telling us generally that they do feel cognitively sluggish or slowed. But just as often they may say that they just feel inefficient. They can't find their words as fluently as they previously did. They're finding that their attention is more easily pulled away from the task at hand. They're distractible. They're no longer able to juggle multiple activities in their workday, for example. They may be more forgetful. And so that they're frequently really bothersome and irksome for patients that I see. Now, for patients who are more severely ill and in the ICU, we may see patients who have had strokes or had more profound cognitive changes. But most of the patients who
这个词的忠实拥护者，因为它缺乏我工作时所需要的特异性。但我们的患者通常告诉我们，他们确实感到认知迟钝或变慢。但同样常见的是，他们可能会说自己只是感到效率低下。他们无法像以前那样流利地找到词汇。他们发现自己的注意力更容易从手头的任务上被分散。他们容易分心。例如，他们不再能够同时处理工作日中的多项活动。他们可能更容易健忘。这些症状对我所见的患者来说经常是非常令人困扰和烦心的。现在，对于病情更严重并住进ICU的患者，我们可能会看到中风或认知变化更深刻的患者。但大多数
are coming through my clinic tend to be those who were able to recuperate at home and did not require an ICU stay. And so for them, it's really this sort of inefficiency and feeling like they're off their game. And they come in wanting to get some help with strategies to improve their functioning. And what are those strategies? I mean, how do you treat brain fog? The first thing we need to do really assess because our patients can tell us that they feel off and they can describe the settings and situations in which they're having difficulties. But as neuropsychologists, our role is then to translate that into what we know about brain and behavior and assess for different types of thinking skills to see where patients are having strengths and where their weaknesses lie.
来到我诊所的患者往往是那些能够在家里康复且不需要入住ICU的人。对他们来说，这确实是一种效率低下，感觉自己不在状态。他们来这里是想寻求一些提高功能的策略。那么这些策略是什么？我的意思是，你如何治疗脑雾？我们首先需要做的是真正进行评估，因为我们的患者可以告诉我们他们感觉不对劲，并且可以描述他们遇到困难的环境和情况。但作为神经心理学家，我们的角色是将这些转化为我们所知的关于大脑和行为的知识，并评估不同类型的思维技能，看看患者的优势在哪里，弱点在哪里。
And then we try to devise compensatory strategies to really capitalize on those areas of strength so that we can minimize the occurrence of cognitive errors in everyday life. We're also really focused on identifying any of the modifiable risk factors for cognitive difficulties. So you can take COVID out of the picture. And if you're fatigued or sleeping poorly, if you're taking cognitively compromising medicines, if you're not taking your medicines correctly and your blood sugars are spiking and falling throughout the day, If you have ongoing anxiety and depression, all those things can contribute to cognitive difficulties. And so if you add on COVID, it really can be a recipe for real troubles in your everyday life.
然后我们尝试设计补偿策略，真正利用这些优势领域，以便最大限度地减少日常生活中认知错误的发生。我们也真正专注于识别任何可改变的认知困难风险因素。所以你可以把新冠排除在外。如果你感到疲劳或睡眠质量差，如果你正在服用会损害认知的药物，如果你没有正确服药导致血糖全天波动，如果你有持续的焦虑和抑郁，所有这些都会导致认知困难。所以如果你再加上新冠，这确实可能成为你日常生活中真正麻烦的根源。
So we want to also make sure that we're keeping an eye out for all of those things that we know we can help address that are more behavioral in nature in terms of helping with sleep hygiene and medication adherence and addressing mental health symptoms. Dr. Rang, are you seeing brain fog in younger? patients as well and how do you help them? What's the treatment? Is it the same? We definitely also sees complaints of rain fog. And I think, I agree that I think the term, it's kind of gray in terms of like it doesn't, it's not very specific about kind of like how it impacts or what, what are the kind of the really kind of thinking kind of changes that they
所以我们也要确保关注所有那些我们知道可以解决的、本质上更偏向行为的问题，比如帮助改善睡眠卫生、服药依从性以及解决心理健康症状。恩博士，你在年轻患者中也看到了脑雾吗？你们如何帮助他们？治疗方法是什么？是一样的吗？我们肯定也看到了关于脑雾的抱怨。而且我认为，我同意这个词在某种程度上是模糊的，因为它不能非常具体地说明它如何影响，或者他们真正经历的思维变化是什么。
really experience. But a lot of times it seems like from a more kind of day-to-day kind of complaints, a lot of people are, or children and adolescents are really reporting and kind of thinking slower, having more memories. or learning challenges than before and feeling kind of more challenges or slower at taking information than they used to. Generally, in terms of kind of recommendations from clinical and a lot of times more school perspective is really kind of, again, helping more environmentally and behavioral strategies to best support children as they kind of acclimate and kind of adjust back to the school environment, school curriculum, and really helping them feel comfortable to kind of resume activity
但很多时候，从更日常的抱怨来看，许多人，或者儿童和青少年确实报告说思维变慢了，记忆力比以前差了，或者学习挑战比以前多了，感觉处理信息比以前更吃力或更慢。通常，从临床和学校的角度来看，建议确实是更多地从环境和行为策略上提供帮助，以最好地支持儿童适应并调整回学校环境和课程，并真正帮助他们感到舒适，从而恢复活动，
rather than kind of stay away or kind of disengage from activity because it feels that many feel so debilitating. And so, you know, I think a lot of the strategies includes like helping like school teams really recognize like how, what does it mean to be kind of pacing the amount of school activities and pacing amount of work and what does that mean in terms of like each person being individually different in the amount of activity they could tolerate too. And then thinking about kind of more kind of day to day. Also, again, similarly, how can we support, like, sleep, like making sure that you're well hydrated, good nutrition, things that are kind of day-to-day behavioral changes that we can do to support
而不是因为感觉太虚弱而远离或脱离活动。所以，我认为很多策略包括帮助学校团队真正认识到，调整学校活动的节奏、调整工作量意味着什么，以及对于每个人来说，他们能承受的活动量各不相同意味着什么。然后考虑更日常的情况。同样，我们如何支持睡眠，确保充足的水分、良好的营养，这些都是我们可以做的日常行为改变，以支持
good health. That could also then support good brain health. And are cognitive rehabilitative exercises for young people different from the ones that you might use with older folks? You know, I think a lot of, like, in terms of for us, like right now, a lot of exercises we're really kind of supporting is also similarly kind of thinking about like cognitive coping skills and thinking about how to manage some of the physical symptoms as well. So especially for a lot of children who are having more like headaches, fatigue, like how to how to best manage those symptoms. In addition to kind of thinking about more effective mood anxiety concerns that often overlaps with a lot of physical symptoms, we think about, you know, when children are suddenly
良好的健康。这反过来也能支持良好的大脑健康。针对年轻人的认知康复练习与你可能对老年人使用的练习不同吗？你知道，我认为在很多方面，就我们而言，目前我们真正支持的很多练习同样是在考虑认知应对技能，并思考如何管理一些生理症状。所以，特别是对于许多有更多头痛、疲劳症状的儿童，如何最好地管理这些症状。除了考虑更有效的情绪焦虑问题（这些问题通常与许多生理症状重叠）之外，我们还会考虑，当儿童突然
having this increase of physical kind of concerns and physical symptoms. Of course, you know, it impacts their day-to-day life a lot. And so that raises a lot of, kind of anxious concerns for children as well. And so in addition to kind of thinking about how to kind of manage some of these physical symptoms, really kind of helping them how to feel that they can keep like keep control and some of the anxiety and some of the kind of mood and negative kind of affective symptoms as well. Early on in the pandemic, there was a lot of publicity about people losing their sense of smell and taste. Is that also associated with long COVID? Are you still seeing a lot of that?
出现这种生理问题的增加和生理症状时。当然，这在很大程度上影响了他们的日常生活。因此，这也引起了儿童很多焦虑的担忧。所以，除了考虑如何管理其中一些生理症状外，还要真正帮助他们感到自己能够保持控制，并管理一些焦虑和一些负面情绪症状。在疫情早期，关于人们失去嗅觉和味觉的报道很多。这是否也与长新冠有关？你们还在看到很多这种情况吗？
and does that also last a long time? I think from the pediatric side, that's not as, I wouldn't say that that's really one of the top, the more frequent symptoms that's often presented in children along COVID. And I think we see a little bit more of, again, like the kind of more of the fatigue, sleep issues that tends to use more a little bit prevalent among this population. So we certainly are still seeing, even with these later waves of COVID-19, a fair proportion of adults who are noticing changes in their sense of smell and taste. And interestingly, it may come back for a bit and then recede again.
这也会持续很长时间吗？我认为从儿科方面来看，我不会说这是长新冠儿童中最常出现的症状之一。我认为我们更多地看到的是疲劳、睡眠问题，这些在这一人群中似乎更为普遍。所以我们当然仍然看到，即使在新冠疫情的后期浪潮中，也有相当一部分成年人注意到他们的嗅觉和味觉发生了变化。有趣的是，它可能会恢复一段时间，然后再次减退。
It appears to be recovering in fits and starts for many of the patients that I'm seeing, which can be frustrating for them because many of us enjoy food and drink. And having that affected can affect their quality of life. How common are the types of specialty long COVID clinics that you work at? how common are these clinics? Is this type of care accessible to all the people who need it, or are they just a lucky few who get to come to you too? From a pediatric site, I think there's not too many of these multidisciplinary kind of clinics, but they are growing. A lot of new clinics are growing across the nation.
在我所见的许多患者中，它似乎在断断续续地恢复，这让他们感到沮丧，因为我们许多人都喜欢食物和饮料。受到影响会影响他们的生活质量。你们工作的这种长新冠专科诊所普遍吗？这些诊所普遍吗？这种护理对所有有需要的人来说都是可及的，还是只有少数幸运儿能来到你们这里？从儿科方面来看，我认为这种多学科诊所并不多，但它们正在增长。全国各地正在涌现许多新的诊所。
That being said, I think access is definitely a problem. And I think there's multiple kind of clinical groups right now thinking about consensus, kind of guidelines for primary health to help support kind of primary care physician. and more to think about how to address some of these symptoms because I think there's a good recognition that not every family may be able to see all the different types of specialists based on where they reside, based on, you know, different kind of social economic barriers as well, the cost and whatnot. And so I think access is definitely like one of the challenges I think and that still kind of presents even, you know, right now years after onset of COVID.
话虽如此，我认为获取途径确实是一个问题。目前有多个临床小组正在考虑针对初级保健的共识指南，以帮助支持初级保健医生，并更多地思考如何解决其中一些症状，因为我认为人们已经充分认识到，并非每个家庭都能根据他们居住的地方、基于不同的社会经济障碍、成本等因素，去看所有不同类型的专家。因此，我认为获取途径确实是挑战之一，即使在新冠爆发多年后的今天依然存在。
And we're still kind of trying to figure out how can we best navigate that and help increase access now, especially at Karen Hicke-Griguer, we have offered some of the telehealth opportunities to make sure that some families who reside in out-of-state who may not have those access to care can still get some access to care through digital or kind of like telehealth means. Yeah, telehealth has been a real great side effect. It's been a real boon that we got out of the COVID pandemic, I have to say. I couldn't agree more. I couldn't agree more the opportunity to see. our patients in their homes, especially our patients with fatigue. It's a real barrier for them to get into a clinic, especially sometimes at a major medical center, which tend to be located in urban
我们仍在试图找出如何最好地应对这一问题，并帮助增加获取途径。特别是在肯尼迪·克里格研究所，我们提供了一些远程医疗机会，以确保一些居住在外州、无法获得此类护理的家庭，仍然可以通过数字或远程医疗手段获得一些护理。是的，远程医疗确实是一个非常好的副作用。我不得不说，这是我们从新冠疫情中获得的一大福音。我完全同意。我完全同意，有机会在患者家中见到他们，特别是我们那些疲劳的患者。这对他们来说是一个真正的障碍，无法进入诊所，特别是有时在大型医疗中心，这些中心往往位于城市
areas and might be quite a drive. But I also agree more broadly that there is a very large need for clinical care. We're seeing specialized clinics pop up all over the country, and it's present in most major medical centers, but there's just simply aren't enough trained and neuropsychologist, clinical psychologist, rehab psychologist, speech language providers, and other types of medical specialists to really handle the flow of patients who are seeking care at this point. How much of your practice is telehealth at this point? We actually see quite a bit about, I think, our last time we checked, almost like half actually, the patients we see are out of state or and are seen via telehealth.
地区，可能需要很长的车程。但我同样更广泛地同意，临床护理的需求非常大。我们看到专业诊所如雨后春笋般在全国各地涌现，大多数大型医疗中心都有，但就是没有足够的训练有素的神经心理学家、临床心理学家、康复心理学家、言语语言治疗师和其他类型的医疗专家来真正处理目前寻求护理的患者流量。你们目前的诊疗中有多少是远程医疗？我们实际上看到了相当多，我想我们上次检查时，几乎有一半我们看到的患者是外州的，是通过远程医疗看诊的。
We're seeing much more now in person as like I think families are also more comfortable. people seeing in person as well. But part of that is I think that, you know, with the multidisciplinary clinic, with them coming in with children and teens coming in all day, getting physical examinations, especially if they're out of state, throwing in a testing on top of that just is a lot of, in terms of children who are already fatigued from long COVID is much more challenging for them to kind to tolerate. And so we've kind of adapted in terms of providing some telehealth or teleneuro psychological evaluations to make it a little bit easier for scheduling and planning for families who are coming from out of state and who might not be able to stay longer term for our kind of multidisciplinary
我们现在看到更多面对面的看诊，因为我认为家庭也更适应面对面看诊。但部分原因是，我认为随着多学科诊所的建立，儿童和青少年整天过来接受体检，特别是如果他们来自外州，再加上测试，对于那些已经因长新冠而疲劳的儿童来说，负担太重，难以承受。因此，我们调整了方式，提供一些远程医疗或远程神经心理学评估，以便为那些来自外州、可能无法长期停留以进行多学科评估的家庭提供更方便的安排和规划。
clear. And most of the patients I see have also been seen first in our multidisciplinary care clinic. And I'm not certain the proportion that are doing telemedicine versus in person for those exams. But once they get to me, quite often I will leave it up to the patient. And less there is something in their record that makes me feel like I need to do their exam in person. And so some patients actually a surprising number prefer to come into the clinic and do things old school, which is wonderful. I love seeing people face to face. But it is also the case that we've now moved to nearly 100% of my feedback sessions when I'm going over the results and giving guidance and talking through my findings of my exam and what I think should come next. We're using
我所见的大多数患者也首先在我们的多学科护理诊所接受过检查。我不确定他们中进行远程医疗与面对面检查的比例是多少。但一旦他们来到我这里，我通常会让患者自己选择。除非他们的记录中有某些内容让我觉得我需要面对面进行检查。所以实际上有相当多令人惊讶的患者更喜欢来到诊所，用老派的方式做事，这太棒了。我喜欢面对面见到人们。但同样的情况是，现在我几乎100%的反馈会议（当我回顾结果、提供指导并讨论我的检查发现以及我认为接下来应该做什么时）都转向了
online and virtual platforms for that almost exclusively, which has been very nice because we're able to connect much more fluidly and patients aren't quite as stressed by having to get into the office. So I'm wondering about some of the treatments available for physical symptoms. It was a recent piece in the Washington Post about long COVID patients who were so desperate for help that they were trying all kinds of unproven therapeutics, everything from ivermectin to blood cell washing to stem cell treatments. Are you seeing this among patients who are coming to you? And how are you treating them? Because, I mean, it sounds like people are pretty desperate in some cases. I'm certainly aware that with the rising number of post-COVID clinics,
在线和虚拟平台，这非常好，因为我们能够更顺畅地联系，患者也不必因为必须去办公室而感到那么大的压力。所以我想知道一些针对生理症状的治疗方法。最近《华盛顿邮报》有一篇文章提到，长新冠患者因为太渴望得到帮助，尝试了各种未经证实的疗法，从伊维菌素到血细胞清洗，再到干细胞治疗。你们在来到你们这里的患者中看到了这种情况吗？你们是如何治疗他们的？因为，我的意思是，听起来有些人在某些情况下非常绝望。我当然知道，随着新冠后诊所数量的增加，
that there are some bad actors out there or some folks who are offering up treatments that don't have efficacy data behind them or may not even have sort of logical mechanistic pathways for improving patient functioning. And so, you know, I always want our patients to be speaking with a trusted medical provider, their primary care doctor internist, if they're thinking about going outside the mainstream. But for the most part, many of my patients, you know, are part of this multidisciplinary care clinic. And so they're already getting good empirically based guidance for the treatment of their symptoms. But I appreciate that there are many folks who are struggling still and feel like they need to branch out and see whatever is out there that might help them.
外面确实存在一些不良行为者，或者一些提供没有疗效数据支持、甚至可能没有改善患者功能的逻辑机制途径的治疗方法的人。所以，我总是希望我们的患者在考虑尝试主流之外的治疗时，能与值得信赖的医疗提供者、他们的初级保健医生或内科医生交谈。但在大多数情况下，我的许多患者已经是这个多学科护理诊所的一部分。所以他们已经获得了针对其症状治疗的、基于实证的良好指导。但我理解，仍有许多人正在挣扎，觉得他们需要去尝试外面可能对他们有帮助的任何东西。
So long COVID has put a spotlight on the phenomenon of post-viral illnesses, because other viruses can cause long-term symptoms as well. How does long-term COVID compare to some of the other post-viral conditions? I think from a symptom perspective, there's actually quite a lot of overlap. A lot of the symptoms like fatigue, headaches, cognitive kind of kind of the brain fog or the kind of cognitive like experience changes. A lot of those we see in a lot of post viral syndromes as well. So, you know, I think like there is like we haven't, I think, reached to that point of really even comparing necessarily, extending across syndromes necessarily. But what we do see is that there's generally a similar overall presentation or at least the kind of constellations of symptoms that for him present when COVID with other.
所以长新冠让人们关注到了病毒后遗症这一现象，因为其他病毒也会引起长期症状。长新冠与其他病毒后遗症相比如何？我认为从症状的角度来看，实际上有很多重叠。许多症状，如疲劳、头痛、认知方面的脑雾或认知体验的变化，我们在许多病毒后综合征中也看到了很多。所以，我认为我们还没有达到那种必然跨综合征进行比较的程度。但我们所看到的是，总体表现通常相似，或者至少是当新冠与其他
kind of viral syndromes, too. That being said, you know, I think there's probably a little bit difference in terms of like when we think about, we tend to see a lot more of these kind of more milder COVID infections compared to potentially those who have more severe, like individuals who might have been hospitalized or in the ICU might have a little bit different presentation than the broader or the more kind of bigger sample of a long COVID, what we've seen in our which are typically the ones without hospitalizations with more milder COVID infections. Dr. Vernorstel, you're saying the same thing? Yes, for the most part. I think there's a fair amount of overlap with existing viral, you know,
病毒综合征同时出现时，所呈现的症状组合是相似的。话虽如此，我认为当我们考虑时，可能在轻度新冠感染与那些可能更严重（如可能曾住院或入住ICU）的个体之间存在一点差异，后者的表现可能与我们所见的大多数长新冠患者（通常是那些没有住院、病情较轻的患者）有所不同。范·奥斯达尔博士，你也这么认为吗？是的，在很大程度上是这样。我认为它与现有的病毒表现有相当多的重叠，
presentations as well as patients who have been characterized as having chronic fatigue syndrome. Those folks, there's a lot that in pots, postural orthostatic hypotension syndrome. There tends to be a lot of overlap in autonomic dysfunction across. suspected ideologies. And so we're trying to figure out what is the common thread, the common mechanistic pathways. But historically, these have been some of the hardest conditions to really understand in terms of what are driving patient symptoms and persistence of patient symptoms. So what are the most important research questions out there from your viewpoints? What do clinicians need to answer really immediately in order to help patients who are struggling
以及那些被定性为患有慢性疲劳综合征的患者。那些人，在体位性心动过速综合征（POTS）方面，在各种疑似病因的自主神经功能障碍中，往往有很多重叠。所以我们正在试图找出共同点，即共同的机制途径。但从历史上看，这些一直是最难理解的疾病，难以弄清是什么驱动了患者的症状以及症状的持续性。那么从你们的观点来看，最重要的研究问题是什么？临床医生需要立即回答什么，才能帮助那些正在与
with long COVID? Well, I think we need more treatment research. I'm very eager to see more treatment outcomes research. We have some very limited data and there are a number of randomized clinical trials for various medications that are in the works that are at various stages. But I think that we need to be looking more. I'm a psychologist, so I love behavioral health interventions to see, what is the effect size for the interventions that we're offering to our patients? What are the most potent ingredients of the treatments that we're providing? And how can we get these and package these interventions in a way that might help us distribute them to more patients more efficiently,
长新冠作斗争的患者？嗯，我认为我们需要更多的治疗研究。我非常渴望看到更多的治疗结果研究。我们有一些非常有限的数据，并且有许多针对各种药物的随机临床试验正在进行中，处于不同阶段。但我认为我们需要看得更多。我是一名心理学家，所以我喜欢行为健康干预，看看我们为患者提供的干预措施的效果量是多少？我们提供的治疗中最有效的成分是什么？我们如何以一种可能帮助我们更有效地将这些干预措施分发给更多患者的方式来包装它们，
since we do believe that they're likely to be helpful in terms of patient functioning and quality of life? Dr. Eng, what are you looking for? What are the big questions? Yeah, I think to also kind of understand, and a lot more kind of the general COVID presentation, if there's any kind of different subgroups in long COVID. I think it's really important to think about kind of more controlled, case-controlled studies and what are comparison groups, which we don't really have in a lot of existing literature right now.
因为我们确实相信它们很可能有助于患者的功能和生活质量？恩博士，你在寻找什么？大问题是什么？是的，我认为还要理解，以及更多关于新冠的一般表现，长新冠中是否有任何不同的亚组。我认为考虑更受控的病例对照研究以及什么是对照组非常重要，而我们目前在许多现有文献中并没有真正做到这一点。
Like, a lot of these are key studies that we have. We don't really, we haven't compared to, for example, children who don't have COVID necessarily, but have been experiencing all the psychosocial stressors associated with the pandemic that we haven't had to experience many years ago. And also thinking about those who have tested positive for COVID versus those have a clinical presentation of COVID, meaning that you have a clinical diagnosis based on symptoms and not necessarily having tested positive for COVID. And then third, kind of thinking about hospitalization, right, those kind of severity of COVID,
比如，我们拥有的很多是关键研究。我们并没有真正与那些没有感染新冠、但一直经历着与疫情相关的社会心理压力的儿童进行比较，这种压力是我们多年前不必经历的。还要考虑那些新冠检测呈阳性的人与那些有新冠临床表现的人，即你有一个基于症状的临床诊断，而不一定新冠检测呈阳性。第三，考虑住院情况，即新冠的严重程度，
that those who have tested for COVID, those who've been hospitalized versus those who might have mild symptoms. Well, this has been really interesting. I want to thank you for the work that you're doing. I know that there are a lot of people out there who need the type of help that you are providing, and I appreciate your joining us here today to talk about the challenge of long COVID. Could I add one thing that I often find helpful to share with patient groups? Because I think there's so much potential for stigma surrounding long COVID symptoms, surrounding the notion that, well, women tend to report symptoms more frequently,
那些新冠检测呈阳性的人，那些住院的人，与那些可能有轻微症状的人。嗯，这真的很有趣。我要感谢你们所做的工作。我知道外面有很多人需要你们提供的这种帮助，我很感谢你们今天加入我们，谈论长新冠的挑战。我可以补充一点我经常发现对患者群体有帮助的事情吗？因为我认为长新冠症状周围存在很大的污名化潜力，围绕着“女性往往更频繁地报告症状”的观念，
or those with preexisting mental health vulnerabilities tend to report more long COVID. And what I really want patients to appreciate is the fact that mental health and cognitive treatments can improve functioning and quality of life does not negate the realness of a patient's symptoms. That dichotomy of this being, quote, unquote, all in your head versus real. It's not a helpful one. We know from a lot of patient populations where the etiology or cause is very obvious. There's a stroke.
或者那些有既往心理健康脆弱性的人往往报告更多的长新冠。我真正想让患者理解的是，心理健康和认知治疗可以改善功能和生活质量，这并不否定患者症状的真实性。那种将此称为“全在你的脑子里”与“真实”的二分法，并不是一个有用的二分法。我们从许多病因或原因非常明显的患者群体中知道，比如中风、
There's a brain tumor. that mental health treatments can help reduce distress and disability and help improve quality of life in these patients. And we have every reason to think that it will be the same for our patients who have long COVID. So we do want to instill a degree of hope and help minimize the stigma that may be out there. That's a great point. Thank you. And like ending on a hopeful note. So again, thank you both for joining me today. This has been really interesting. Thank you for having me. Thanks for having us. You can learn more about how psychologists are contributing to the research on long COVID
脑肿瘤，心理健康治疗可以帮助减轻痛苦和残疾，并帮助改善这些患者的生活质量。我们有充分的理由认为，对于我们患有长新冠的患者来说，情况也会一样。所以我们确实想灌输一定程度的希望，并帮助最大限度地减少可能存在的污名化。这是一个很好的观点。谢谢。喜欢以希望的基调结束。所以再次感谢两位今天加入我的节目。这真的很有趣。谢谢邀请我。谢谢邀请我们。您可以了解更多关于心理学家如何为长新冠研究做出贡献的信息。
in the November, December, issue of APA's magazine, The Monitor, which is on our website at www.apa.org slash monitor. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you heard, please leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyian. Thank you for listening.
在APA杂志《The Monitor》的11月/12月刊中，您可以访问我们的网站www.apa.org/monitor查看。您也可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org，或者Apple、Stitcher以及您获取播客的任何平台找到《Speaking of Psychology》往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请留下评论。如果您有任何意见或对未来节目的想法，可以发送电子邮件至SpeakingofPsychology@apa.org。《Speaking of Psychology》由Lee Weinerman制作，我们的音频编辑是Chris Kondyian。感谢您的收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是Kim Mills，代表美国心理学会。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。